citizens of the reject
Nation it's me Tera Ericson alongside
this guy say your name Aon Alexander o
that was a good one we're watching saw
four we know there's been a delay but
it's because you guys need to go watch
the other ones 1 2 three we've been in a
roll you need to get the fuse up on
those because then we could keep going
that's what we want to do we want to
watch all of them so you guys got to
make it really popular share with your
family and your friends you got to leave
a like you got to type in a comment you
got to also ring the
bell ring the bell also thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these
videos we appreciate
you also we call you super sexy if you
join patreon so you should get over
there and join it because you can syn up
with your entire your full copy your
entire full copy all of your copies of
all the things you sink it up with me
and him and we watch it together like
one big happy family are you ready to
watch sore I was born ready to oh my God
my God that's so fun okay let's get to
it in three two
one ooh oh that's a pie that's a gross
that's a that's a I mean that's a dead
body that's a gross foot but also
yes that oh
my subject's name is John framer a
52-year-old male caucasian he seen
better
days damn that's a deep
cut okay are we going to see where she
screwed the hole is there no better
protocol for just like ripping it just
off like that oh God we have a recent
rectangular transsection to the left
ocal yeah remember when she uh
took the
off what's the point of this why this
homie's brain are we just trying to see
her work or like how it maybe are they
trying to be like why were you
insane are you going to save his brain
what are you going to do with that thing
are we going to put put it in like a jar
with that creepy juice that the one
Zodiac Killer used to
do we going to put his brain in a new
body so he can keep
jigsa good God why wow this prop is
pretty amazing though it does look
really real so art Department great
job what is that no that's stomach
that's what a stomach looks like m why
are we cutting it
open cuz there's a message in there for
the next game all right oh my God what
if there is this what if there is oh my
God oh my God you I once you said it I
was like that's a brilliant idea wow I
he would do that my God you saw it where
is
it was in his
stomach what je how did he even eat that
what is that
what is it a matchbook with Clues you
right oh my God covered it in wax so it
wouldn't dissolve with the with the acid
in your system is that how that works
yeah cuz it would probably dissolve that
wa this is insane oh my God it's a t oh
my oh my God this is wild are you a
detective you are probably the last
manand standing you think it's over just
because I'm dead it's not over the games
have just begun oh oh have they now wow
all right let's get into it let's do it
oh oh is he has no eyes he's oh he's in
a moreor what do you call it oh they're
so sh oh no no that's my worst
nightmare
mouth is shut up is that Elijah Wood no
oh my God I almost lost it oh my God
he's he's a
cheap no no
no and there's another guy there's
another chain I think where coming from
the the front angle there it's I thought
so okay no that's just just a god a plug
or something I thought they were going
to do like a see no evil speak no evil
will hear no evil like somebody's ears
would be tied up but now I'm like oh if
he one guy can speak the other guy can
see for him yeah how does that tie into
oh he has to get that
key
okay oh this is so messed
up what what happens what happens now
yeah exactly the engine goes
on oh my God it wraps the chain oh oh no
this is sick so both their necks are
going to get yeah ti so and he can't
even tell them dude no like you got to
get his attention hurry up code like
like clap or something tap clap tap on
that wall be like Broski
key oh
bro oh oh get the key get the key oh
good job good job good job good job guy
oh ah get the
bow
oh he's going
to this is so messed up oh my
God yeah a big guy who can't see versus
a oh my God oh my
God okay this is not good
[Applause]
no oh
[Music]
God would you would you rather your
mouth sew or your eyes showed my mouth
yeah oh that looks so painful just like
how do we up the antie if both jigsaw is
dead and Lady jigsaw is dead where are
we going from
here is that the dude from the last one
yeah I feel like I recognize him we have
a device you get eyes in there before
you go in get some eyes in
here it's funny to see iroot because
that's normally a I associate that with
a floor vacuum I associate that with
Will
Smith that
[Music]
too oh no it's a hanging body how's it
hanging oh what
Ken oh it's the detective that I like
that I think wasib open yeah that I'm
like oh I believe
yeah oh oh this must take place right
after the three oh oh man yeah
oh no God
damn [__] I'm special agent Lindsay
Perez this is Special Agent Peta strong
she was our liais on open the door you
will find me seen that guy a the key
that came from our last message you know
him not personally but he works a lot
she's still in shows right now crie
scene photographer flash picked up this
bullet casing it was lodged between the
body and the device there's something
about like at least this section of the
movies that feel like a like a TV show
yes that gets kind of shot that way too
yeah it's shot like a TV show yes this
wasn't done by Amanda young excuse me
well you guys just knew that already
that Amanda's part of this she couldn't
get her up there alone John crra was
bedridden cancer patient he's brains not
braa he was also an engineer he could
have R police or someone else could have
helped them oh a third person we're here
to find the person your department
couldn't detect if the one helping jigsa
am man young the plot thiens yeah you
found a harle doll in your possession
it's a toy how about the tricycle a
grown man has a tricycle his whole life
look this is tuck so why don't we start
at the end and that's what way back
would they release books about jigsaw
while he's actively like killing people
Eric's been missing for 6 months Carri
was gone for 4 days yeah what I'm in it
until I find him finding his body is not
going to vindicate us finding him alive
will okay interesting we're at a
timeline now who's he rigar SWAT
Commander everyone around him keeps
dying I think it's interesting how uh
each movie is like a this barrel of
monkeys kind of yeah they're all linked
there's someone that it links to the
last the one before it yes I need to
help my mom for a few days just come
with me I can't what you can't do is
save everyone if someone told me this
was a scene from Law and Order I'd
believe them yeah totally it's also the
lighting too yeah like the lighting in
the last one we without CSI this one
like Law and Order type TV show you know
D Network TV absolutely what was rig
watching Jill tux interrogation she was
jigsaw ex it's old oh
looks like another doctor one missing
from the hospital I think maybe it's
thanks check it out another doctor what
is he hold it stuffed owl yeah it looks
like it's some sort of stuffed
animal you next
victim
kidna oh
[__] dang he has like 22
ABS he is very
ripped oh he already has it prepped like
that wasn't there before that
plastic God I felt it I felt it I just I
thought it was going to come from the
wood over there so I kept
[Laughter]
waiting this guy seems
off okay
print that casing yep we got a match
Jesus you check this
twice oh no yep our next victim I knew
it it's always the first cops with the
next victim since the last one he loves
a bubble bath torture he loves bath
stuff oh
God o don't do that n don't do that
let get out of the way what oh it just
turned on the TV okay okay hello officer
rake welcome to your rebirth you have
remained untouched your obsession stop
those around you from making the wrong
choices tonight I give you the
opportunity to face your obsession Eric
matthus is still alive what what he has
but 90 minutes to save himself detective
Hoffman's fate is linked to Eric's
survival will you learn how to let go
and truly save them oh
wow oh the time begins there's no way
that room is in his apartment right did
he turn his his apartment into a trap
did it that fast with a that block of
ice is so
big this must be a strong guy helping
him with all this stuff who oh that what
that be it's like like an electric chair
what who Mr pums you guys know I hate
the pig hair oh I can't why does it oh
it's a
victim see what I see beneath the Mas
lies a criminal undeserving of the life
she
leads your obsession tells you to save
the victim I tell you to walk
away
oh what oh no listen to jsaw Y byebye
head byebye
byebye
out cut off her hair if scissors TT
shoot through it shoot through her
hair send a bullet right through that
ponytail through it blah BL BL wait wait
scissors scissors knife knife what
there's nothing in here use the paper oh
goder come on man shoot through it
please come
back I thought he was right for a second
thought to be right oh me too I thought
he was going to like shoot that which
wouldn't have really worked he would
have wasted a lot of bullets but yeah
may you got up close that worked I guess
oh oh here we
go telling you shoot off the ponytail
you might be all right or just like rip
it from the you're strong you got 500
Muses my God what just went into
who no
[Music]
no nope I don't want getting that
scalped one I got another one what do
you mean you got another one you could
have just cut her hair and I know you
couldn't find scissors but I mean hom
this is your fault you kind of oh my God
he told you not to save her oh Lord okay
she got a mullet
now give her some give her some what is
she looking for how her some cream she
knows what's a hell bro what this is why
you listen this is why no she's going
she going try to kill you
now dummy oh my goodness are you doing
why this is why you listen to him he
just saved you you crazy he's the game
master this could be another Amanda
situation she's taking over yeah I mean
come on oh is
he is he ripping
it
damn whoa that was an insane transition
what a crazy transition that was amazing
that was cool that was cool I'll give
you that I'll give you that Bravo on
that editing to think that through that
transition you have to know that ahead
of time yes yes yes snaps to that moveie
sign me up yes sir hello Brenda oh my
goodness to play a game this math will
use these photos to sentence you for
your crimes what's your crimes let him
save your life and accept your fate to
rot in prison or kill him and guarantee
your freedom
H Mr
ultimatum One Life what the second one
say take another life one Saves a Life
one takes one away oh
I'm really surprised homie for number
two is still alive yeah me too like got
a broken foot yeah on the
ice oh look at he looks so
different
no yeah I remember that who that that
yeah who who is this I think it's
another cop I guess there's another cop
you think it's a guy next to him could
be cuz I feel like he's weird he had
that stuffed owl I don't know what that
was about
suery it was dark show us your face show
us your godd dang face was that slop
that looks
gross I got
one is it her oh she died okay she di
from scalping I guess maybe you bleed
out yeah bleed out from the head how
explain detective Matthews He's Alive 6
months jigsaw never kept anyone that
long no one but Amanda young you think
he's been fixed by these
six some of these people haven't even
seen yet it's a setup to announce rig as
the accomplice or setup for his
Alibi four four walls build a home one
of these pictures doesn't
belong who it this is who we're looking
for who is it and why doesn't she belong
on the wall she'll talk where
she oh she's the oh she's a lady that
was his ex yeah that they've been
talking to
okayy who the heck is this have we met
this guy yet and it begins sir
sir sir can I help you we saw that guy's
picture yeah the guy from downstairs
okay so this is
all
no
no oh I'm sorry I sneezed I'm sure you
did sure he did oh that's hair that's
hair in a box that's his wife no don't
tell me it's his wife's head in the Box
she needed you no don't tell me that
don't tell me that please oh this going
to be so sad what's in the box what's in
the
[Music]
box oh it's a big head oh than goodness
I thought it was her head jeez oh it's
that guy downstairs he got to kill that
guy if he wants his wife to survive I
bet that guy s and plus some other juice
I don't like the way he's kissing that
dog you must feel what I feel in the
Next Room are the tools to his salvation
his life is in your hands only key can
save himself you must hide your identity
oh what on what your photos are doing at
the crime scene four walls build a home
ringing a Bells cherish your life
cherish your life is the concept of this
whole Clinic was built on cherish your
life I've been here for three hours shut
the up you shut up I don't want to do
that it's your problem you're my problem
takes a motto from your drug Clinic
designed to help people isn't he kind of
like a cheap Nick Cage I can see it you
know you know there's a lot of people
out there looking for answers wanting to
place blame on someone that
person is
you can't even see it
now look like he looks like Nick Cage
mixed with Roo uhhuh and he has like
Nick Cage uh gestures sometimes too he's
given the white arms M doing like the
the head shakes and everything was she
pregnant I saw a baby bump there
does that mean that they had a kid and
the kid is the one finishing it in the
room that just came in I thought the kid
would be younger than that I don't know
I don't know what the timeline is here
yeah you're
right I got a surprise for you or is it
like that she lost the baby and that's
what turned him into
psychopath
oh that's something the jigsaw we know
it's the the first model I'd be like I
got to board this baby if you think
that's a toy uh-uh uh-uh sir nope get
out that ugly thing on my face uhuh this
was a mistake it Happ damn you took the
mask off already I I paid for this just
just let me just let me go
okay you paid for
this one takes it away try that in the
door try
that is he going to get
shot get back get back get back oh is it
proof of what he did what did he do dude
he do something
sick what is it I didn't see oh he he
killed oh oh is that his like dungeon
that's his dare that's his his lair yeah
shoot him shoot him
exactly uh or tie him up tie him up I'd
say here's your own treatment no you
ain't getting out of this buddy what do
you know about Eric Matthews I don't
know who that
face rig man before you a victim or a
perpetrator of
violence his salvation is out of your
hands set him free from Life set him
free oh no this pissing me off bro oh my
[Music]
God is that him is that him in the tape
cuz then I know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's him in the tape that's him in the
tape
girl oh nope NOP
NOP get in the bed bro you got to com
now get in the bed H nope put it on put
it on oh my God I would have I would
have just stabbed him already and been
like you're going to bleed out while
we're doing this buddy shoot his PP
off hand him the tools that will save
his life what are
they oh are they going to shock
him do it do whatever it is do whatever
it is cuz I don't play that do it can
you see the vain you have brought them
you have used your body as an instrument
of abuse what is more important your
eyes which have led you blindly astray
or your body is he going to take his
limbs off is that what the decide
quickly though in 60 seconds the choice
will be made for
you
oh
oh collect the other one buddy say
bye-bye body too bye-bye is it his to
snap into his legs I see you later dude
see you oh I hope he's still alive with
no legs and one eye taken out and he
just bleeds out for a minute she to save
life go back to where it all began yep
you going to have to tell me how you got
those was this an accident or did
someone do this to you on purpose no you
stop it from happening if you tell me
the truth is that the daughter from the
last one take a seat please I want to go
home now
no son of the [__] is lying he's done
this before she's allowing it hell know
sometimes these kids just get out of
control hey take it easy go
yes again payback baby get out now you
just made the biggest mistake of your
life God I bet he's he's some big
attorney let him make one more yeah
maybe three more that felt good that
felt good could have felt better but it
felt good do you know anything about the
Chinese zodiac I didn't just get
pregnant it was carefully planned yeah
honey want some company what are you
doing what are you
doing what I forgot my jacket that's the
most aggressive way you could have done
that right there why did he pop up come
on like what he was hiding why are you
jumping like a little kid just you're
being weird I'd be like step five feet
back I'm going to throw it to you and
get the F out my face of course oh yep
you can open up that door open door open
it give me the
drugs
what
oh yeah you smash the baby you freaking
God
oh my God he killed the
baby oh I bet you he was he had to be
one of the first victims I bet you I
hope he was or maybe he's going to be
recycled
soon like no I need some help
here is that how that works the tummy
gets smashed it's baby yeah I mean if
the if the head is right there for a
tiny little fetal thing that's that big
that amount of pressure probably right
through the head right yeah BR all I
wanted to do is help them you can't help
them they have to help themselves they
don't deserve your
help okay let's Rie nice transitions are
awesome they're killing it look at these
photos tell me how you feel tell me how
you feel enraged exactly jigel wanted
rig to see what he sees he wants him to
feel what he feels he's being recruited
yeah I mean that's what I thought the
the last guy was being
done I mean he's definitely recruited
now cuz we saw him put on the mask well
I don't think he's recruited yet he ful
but like his little like he's being
recruited is like does make a lot of
sense especially how he's like I have to
do this to get I think it's Jeff I think
Jeff is the the new jigsaw no that
wouldn't make sense never mind find me
if you're in Danger get
[Music]
step
we're the two jigsaw targets we're the
what two jigsaw targets
okay the the reason I said that is cuz
it seemed like he's putting this dude
through a similar thing of what the guy
through three went through but then he
killed the guy oh
[Music]
no timeline
wise we going to show it are we just
going to show show who it is come on
now it's that guy from the beginning who
opened his mouth somebody to take a look
at it all right my client has a broken
nose and a fractor cheekbone
administrative leave with pay is not
acceptable he was the lawyer for the
abusive husband you're good you know
you're you're obvious thick as thieves
this Reon but it'll it'll come back to
you you know that right I mean one day
someday it will it will come back to you
the lawyer
he was the lawyer for the guy we saw
with the kid he beat up his kid yeah
that's a seed or twist you should have
planted earlier cuz it's not too crazy
reveal what is going
on oh
no dead couple oh it's
him and his wife where is the
girl this one's very similar to three
yeah the countdown and moving through
the rooms yeah putting someone through a
test
yes oh okay she's still
alive oh my God the human body is a
fascinating organism it can withstand
the most brutal injury how many Broken
Bones have you suffered at the hands of
your husband can you disconnect from the
one thing that is brought you and others
so much
pain remove the ties That Bind or bleed
to death from your inactivity the choic
is you
are oh they're through each other's
bodies yes that's why hers are in places
that she won't die or bleed out but his
it'll go
through there he goes what an intricate
mhm you got to put it in at such an
angle a to make hers not go into organs
but his yeah and his body's lower than
hers totally like oh God fascinating
experience is a harsh teacher if you are
to save as I save then you will see that
the person before you is but a student a
student the key to finding your next
destination is just off the
map
Tracy go
home yeah that g keeps coming up yeah at
the clinic he has to go to the clinic
you got to save
yourself oh interesting can't do it for
you your life is in her hands Rick
didn't kill this guy his wife did she
identified officer rig said he saved her
pass rig's judgment got fixed and got
her Freedom back okay detective going
off of fair little information solving
crimes
yeah he's been really quick with
everything right they were all
represented by a lawyer named art blank
he got them all off yeah he's also Jill
Tuck's
lawyer look
out okay God damn where's the new game
being played find that place we find rig
we got a second address there's a
co-owner who Jill tuck where's the
building here this
building play it you guys know how the
game goes I say search the room to make
sure there's no traps first but hello
Agent Perez your partner agent St will
soon take the life of an innocent
man eyes are moving what is
that
what
paramedic shut up all over her face damn
shout out to the makeup and the props
Department still I was like those look
pretty real I don't know what that is in
there but looks good
yeah this is shot a little more
cinematically like it's a kind of like
it's like the camera is at a down angle
there's it seems like it's more smooth
like it might be on a dolly or a
following shot versus the other stuff
feel was very TV is it's very TV it's
just
like ooh
uh-oh better yeah it's just more
interesting to look at and maybe that
was obviously here's the good news if
this other guy passes his test the three
of us can go free yep he's a pawn if you
don't stay on the block your partner
gets electrocuted there you go where the
hell is our BL he's a business partner
he's a friend he's the accomplice we we
have been looking for whenever see the
cop do that in the show I just imagine
his breath smells really bad yeah we got
4 F 40 families John low income families
you can't just walk away You're their
savior John
the I don't think he could ever forgive
me in his mind our time was over he was
diagnosed with cancer soon after that
okay she has a key on her necklace look
at this what is this h why do you have
these little pictures what have you done
[Music]
D he was his first
game oh he's getting inspired by the
kids with the
pigs oh that's how the pig mask began it
would seem so Random right let me go I
could let you go though I'll give you a
tool to reclaim your life to discard the
vices that have so corrupted your soul I
don't have a
soul this guy I want to play a game you
prayed on the kindness of others by
bringing the ugliness inside you out
into the open we have to mat your face
with the ugliness of your soul oh just
lean forward into the knives with your
face press hard
enough and you'll release the arm like
restraints
oh going to lean into it yeah he's going
to do it right just close your eyes and
head head first head butt yeah just like
do it why are you doing this so slow
speed it up just get it over with hard
with pressure don't go back and forth
you're going to make it worse good God
what are you doing buddy just bang your
head through those knives real quick you
just got to touch the thing in front of
you that's all you got to do is doing it
all wrong I have no respect for him as a
drug dealer or as a person with his life
In His Hands he's going to die is come
on being a dummy oh he did it okay after
way too many tries right you're
get his face doesn't look too caught up
what is that thing hanging
off that's what you get dumbass oh my
goodness
you learn
nothing it's a flashback within a
flashback what is
this who's going to go in
there four walls build a home your son
was named after John's first building
right yes where is
it where is it God damn usually you want
to do like a good cop bad cop kind of
thing just all bad cop
homie oh finally we get back to him I
forgot about him right forgot he was
even in this movie dude we've had like
four story lines in this hour and a half
movie we got his we got the cops we got
the
flashbacks oh what did it say it says
remember who you are saving um his wife
[Music]
yeah someone got it before
him
you are running low on
time where did I go wrong I lost a
friend oh in a bit
[Music]
[Laughter]
end oh God what what does that do
rupture his spine oh oh that's going to
that's going to do something some
damage
okay yeah you're right yeah you didn't I
knew that the the whole time the whole
time you he looked different you just
got it now that his mouth okay I love
that I know I
know Jeff what Jeff it is it is here he
goes it's all culminated
well you have a gun I would just shoot a
second I saw a body through the door but
then I guess that wouldn't really do
anything you'd just still be hanging
there I'm standing right
here what is the timeline of all this
exactly this is they all in the same
location right now that's what I'm
trying to figure out this is confusing
cuz or is he in a Flash is Jeff in a
flashback cuz the lighting is a little
different well kind of cuz this is Jeff
approaching the
area yeah yeah this is the end of
three and that's where he is now so he's
are we doing a flashback and the
detective is exactly where we're seeing
Jeff right now no cuz it was like um Cur
yeah okay this is confusing cuz I'm like
this can't be happening at the same time
cuz they already have jigsaws body at
the autopsy they shall release us when
the timer's
[Music]
up lost you and your wife tonight which
is okay yeah now always in that that
area not in that exact room but that
area don't open the
door yeah I mean that's exactly what I
was saying to do I
guess yep
damn oh nice little electrocution chair
there
now we're in the
room where is my daughter you oh now
we're just going to kill J okay all
right this is not happening at the same
time where is what is the timeline of
this exactly where cuz see this is
immediately after 3 and J's body's still
there what what is happening what is
going on have we just been following him
in a flashback the entire time I think
so wait put your
fuing
[__]
what if you are hearing this then you
have reached detective Matthews and
detective Hoffman tonight you face your
obsession will you learn how to let go
you failed your final death is he oh
he's an exra yes him remember how I said
he was weird with the owl
thing what is that oh that's Nicholas
Cage no wasn't there two white cops this
wasn't done by Amanda young excuse me
and she couldn't get her up was that guy
that
guy go
home that's not Nicholas Cage that's the
other cop yeah that's not him that's why
I was like what I had a feeling this is
going to be a reprisal of one where like
the guy who's who you think is innocent
is not game
over but why though
[Music]
yeah what this does not make sense the
math isn't mathing cuz the whole reason
this game started was because they found
the the tape in the the autopsy room I
promise that my work will continue by
hearing this tape some will assume that
this is over but I am still among you
the games have just
begun yeah because that he the
the oh
so no see cuz he was in that weird
autopsy room and I feel like he then he
could have
just
I'm confused unless that's uh hold on
okay listen he was just there he closes
them in they're in that [__] room
right right he leaves he's the new guy
he wasn't the new guy when he found him
and got the tape from the autopsy he had
to know that had to be the beginning for
the detective right no it couldn't have
been the the beginning for the detective
because jigsaws body was already on the
Opera
body was still there maybe he wrapped
him back and put him back there no CU
they ripped over RI open everything I
know and we're coming into this as Jeff
CU him getting locked in there is
happening simultaneously while three is
happening right like the immediate event
of three is when that's going
down that's why I'm
confused but uh I say well then that
means he had to be involved before he
even listened to the tape
right like to set all of that up I mean
yes obviously I'm just saying the
timeline of the
[__] the tape and him going the it's
now all just starting and then him
choosing to be like I'mma carry this
through I feel like he was assisting
before but once he saw the tape was
confirmation that that it's just begun
that it's just begun and now he needs to
take over the leg it up okay okay yeah
all right sorry I just was like that
wasn't as clear for me no it wasn't
clear for me either it's it's very timey
wiy and plays with plays with continuity
so think they trying to set us up to be
confused with those transitions as well
yeah I was going to be like that's one
of the best things about this movie the
way that they thought through those
transitions I mean it's it was awesome
how they did that I always think like
how do you do that you have to like
frame up a camera and the person has to
be in the same spot great but I feel
like that was there to utilize the
confusion for us at the end as to where
they both were in this time line yeah uh
I because any time he'd cross a wall the
other guy would cross a wall and we're
like are they in the same place or not
right yeah that was the ending of that
was wild like it
was that was odd it wasn't it felt like
to me it didn't feel as like
whoa the other ones because it just had
I feel like a little too much going on
it had a lot going on for this hour and
a half movie we just left the first guy
that we thought was our lead for like a
good 40 minutes and he didn't come back
till the end and the wife never came
back and also what the f is the why why
is there a key on the wife's necklace
y'all I'm just saying there's a bunch of
key stuff in here and why does she have
a key on her necklace if she comes back
I will not be surprised
I mean and the wife never came back his
wife like that that was the lesson who
do you truly sa right like clearly his
story is not over cuz he didn't die at
the end of the movie he was in a
position to to be die or trapped kind of
like our other previous leads yeah and
we still don't know what happened to to
Jeff's daughter Jeff's dead now but her
his daughter is somewhere not having
oxygen within like this jigsaw place
that he's designed or his um his
building or whatnot it's very it was
very tiny Wy very confusing with this
continuity um it's getting a little a
little up its own ass but you know I
still I still
enjoy the movie um I don't think I
enjoyed it as much as the first three
but I'm still entertained and I'm still
like following along cuz we we've
watched three of these now four of these
now so I'm invested in like what's going
on it's just getting a little uh
convoluted but that being said uh I will
say that the theme of this overall movie
about him letting people make their own
choices letting them have to save
themselves I thought that was very
interesting um cuz yeah I as we go along
with these movies I kind of there's this
recurring motif of like jigsaw setting
up these traps to teach people a lesson
and I think that yeah prior to going
into this franchise I thought it was
just like a straight up horror thing
straight up like torture Point thing but
like there's there is intent behind it
which I can respect I really cly enough
I don't think this movie was as gross as
the last one I thought it was like
messed up but I don't think it was as
bad yeah I don't think so I don't think
so either except for at the beginning
with that the whole body stuff I was
like that was a little rough but like I
do agree that with the revenge or like
Vengeance really in in him especially
going to that guy's room and us us
feeling like a sense of Vengeance that
he dies in a really brutal way he's like
yay and the fact that the dad who beat
his kid and his wife dies yay people who
did bad things we got to see which is is
always like oh cool like I'm glad that
that person died but like the it it
really does add to like his civil
engineering side of him of like how many
games are we playing
today it's like he it's that that was a
lot of moving Parts which I still also
really enjoyed it I do like the the
intelligence behind um that's factoring
in why these people are dying I like
that the reasoning yeah um but I don't
think we got enough of the reasoning
from the cop at the end right when he
was just like game over maybe we'll find
that out but in every single other one I
realized that the the reasoning was put
on our lead I don't remember his name
the guy our lead with the wife uh that
reasoning was given at the end of like
why he was where he was but the
secondary guy who was like in on it we
didn't have the reasoning at the end
which I liked like why why did you get
stuck here how did it happen I assume
that's just a foundation a set up for
the next one um I feel like that's what
it was with uh the previous one with
Amanda we didn't really find out her
reasoning until until later but we
didn't even know that oh yeah you're
right at the end we did know and then it
was revealed yes yeah we find out the
end of we find out the end of two that
aanda was in on it and then three get
her reasoning we get her in there so
we're setting him up for it which is
cool but I'm like yeah there was a just
a lot of moving Parts which I think
slightly took away from maybe the
intelligence and the movement of the
game if we had maybe stayed just on the
lead the entire he's not even the lead I
don't know his name I'm just G to call
him Dan Dan the guy with the wife okay
if we had stayed with Dan are talking
about our our main character here the
main character rig goodness freaking
gracious there's a lot of characters I
don't blame you cuz I was like Oh I
thought rig was going to be our lead
like the entire time then we left him
like I said for 40 minutes I uh like
maybe if we just stayed with him
throughout on sort of these like
Vengeance kills and then landed in this
room and the reveal of maybe this cop
but we we did move around a lot which I
still found entertaining I think what it
is is that the fir for me still the
first two movies are the best of the
franchise that we've seen so far is
because well one the first one treated
it as an isolated incident it was like
it's a its own complete story but every
movie since then has treated it like an
episode of this like longer story and I
feel like we're not getting complete
stories with complete characters no
we're just leaving it as a dead end
which is smart for uh you know to make a
bunch of movies after where people are
like oh I want to see that story but
can't we also secretly hide it like did
between one and two where two was like
what instead of now we're getting a
little more obvious at the end with
who's going to be next yeah which I'm
like a if they hit it right like one and
two made it made it seem like a closed
off story and then if we get another one
we're like oh is that person that could
be fun yeah I think the the twists in
the first two were the most shocking but
I
think these these uh these last two the
I'm still very much entertained as I'm
watching it I still really like the the
whole series it's just yes yeah I don't
think it's it's as like mindblowing like
I don't know if it's because it's a
character that was very much in the
background cuz the reason why Amanda
being revealed was such a mindblown she
was an active part of the story from
start to finish whereas this guy was
very much he didn't really have many
lines he was just kind of there so just
like oh all right I I guess it's it's
this guy is the new jigsaw the new uh
member of this team sure um but yeah it
was it was fun I I look forward to
seeing the next part I'm a little
frustrated by the fact that you leave
three in such a big Cliffhanger that
Jeff killed jigsaw and his daughters in
a room and his wife just died and then
we don't really address that until the
very end and when we do finally see him
he just is killed immediately so we
never really resolve the issue from
three and I imagine when this came out I
have to imagine that frustrated people
cuz you leave leave on such a big
Cliffhanger and I feel like from 2 to
three there was even though it was a
start of a new story they did a good job
of like connecting those two and closing
those stories together they closed it
and this one felt very un like I don't
know I wouldn't be surprised if it's
like Jeff Survived The Gunshot because
he was in the autopsy room with the
Nicholas Cage cop helped sew him up cuz
he's a cop and now it's I don't know
it's two of the cops and Jeff like I
don't I don't know but I do agree that
there's a lot of I think there's
open-ended Parts in this that bug us
because before the other movies tied up
in a pretty bow and this one not really
but still a lot of fun I we did agree
that like the more cinematic shots
happened in with the wallberg where
Wahlberg was with the ice and all that
um and then the rest of it was shot sort
of there was one point where I was like
they played with a a a fast push in
dolly shot with the Nick Cage cop just
with his gun and when they were walking
up to the room and I was like is this
going to reveal something to us and no
it was just they were like this will
probably look cool which I did I did
like that shot I thought it was cool but
um yeah it did it did give off a little
more TV feels than maybe maybe the
others I feel like the first one looked
more cinematic throughout maybe two as
well but um yeah I still liked I liked
all the actors in this I'll be surprised
to see what the wife does cuz she has a
key on her neck okay and if that doesn't
come back I'm going to be like really
come on now come on guys come on what
are you doing what what are we doing
here um but yeah I still liked it I
would give this one because I'm really
still a big fan of this of this
franchise I would give this one a
[Music]
seven 6 and A2 out of 10 or seven out of
10 only because the Indie I was like a
little confused and all the other ones
really tied it up so well and I want it
to live up to that standard so I'm
excited to watch the next ones what
about you no I I agree I was kind of as
you were talking I was kind of going
over where my rating would be and I'm
kind of fluctuating between that area as
well between like a six and a seven so I
think 6.5 sounds good but just cuz it's
a 6.5 doesn't mean I didn't enjoy the
experience it's just like judging the
total the totality of that experience as
a whole uh but yeah I'm still very much
invested want to see where this goes and
yeah I'm I'm also excited for the next
one yeah and I love the I that ice move
awesome like coming down and smashing
his head cool yeah um still a lot of
this stuff in it it stands alone as like
that's rad um and awesome so yes I'm
excited to see the next ones any last
thoughts before you get out of here uh
what's up with that cop I don't know
where's the daughter where's Jeff's
daughter I don't so many questions I
still have yeah but I guess we just got
to keep watching to find out we got to
keep watching it make sure that you guys
go back and watch our other ones 1 2 3
put this one on here leave a like leave
a comment do all that juice for all of
them so we can continue with this um
because we're having a lot of fun and we
love you guys so that's it I think we're
getting out of here and uh look at my
spooky Nails okay happy Halloween time
we'll see you on the next one
bye all right guys we got to do some
Patron catch UPS here and going within
the theme we're going to use our friends
over at chat gbt to help us get to know
what people might be like when our
patrons interact with each other now
we're down to our last few and here's
the problem with the last few yes we
don't know them personally that well no
normally we have some facts about them
and then we throw it in there but now
we're just going to have to take a guess
on what they're like to judge people
based on their name have to assume some
of their personality traits just off of
the little bits of interactions that
we've had with them definitely all right
so let's get this show on the road so I
have a YouTube channel I'm prompting
chat you to we going to shout out our
patrons are super sexy rejects uh which
pair should we go with John oh let's do
Brian Perry and pandemic Jones oh my God
what's pandemic Jones's real name Paul
Brian Perry and P and Paul Jones yes all
right all right I want you to write a
scene only do the dialogue of
them of them um escaping from
Leatherface in yeah oh no it's we'll put
this in the saw video jigsaw escaping
from
jigsaw create a they are trapped
together create a trap that they have to
survive together to get out of yeah and
what must they learn throw jigsaw in
there at the beginning yeah a jigsaw
tape the beginning a jigsaw a jigsaw
tape some facts about Brian Perry and
Paul
Jones all right Paul likes to be called
pandemic Jones likes to be called
pandemic Jones that's true it's awarded
nickname uh he's a very upbeat and uh
good-spirited person upbeat and good
spirited person okay but but why would
he need to be taught a lesson from
jigsaw cuz he wants to cause a pandemic
cuz he's too online he's always online
he wants to cause a pandemic he wants to
cause a pandemic that's even better um
we yeah always online never living too
much in this in the real world in the
real world yeah in the moment um he he
has has has stolen fruit from the
grocery
oh no and uh let's see how old do you
think he is uh he's like 23 23 years old
yeah
male um very buff very buff but with
glute impacts uh glute uh implants and
lies to people that he did it all
natural oh no oh my God okay now Brian
Perry I I really don't know much about
this guy shout him out all the time so
he's going to take I guess um he's a cop
I think in real life he's a cop it's a s
I believe Brian is probably our oldest
Patron he is 98 years old he is he's old
on 98 years old he's been scamming his
Medicare been scamming his Medicare uh
has had has had three to four wives yes
um who have all
mysteriously disappeared disappeared um
o he's uh obsessed with Mel Gibson
yeah yeah he's a he loves q and on loves
Q how do you spell q and on that's how
woke I am space a n o n loves q and on
just the letter Q uh uh ooh he's uh he
he he makes inappropriate comments to
people online inappropriate comments to
people online
uh and but overall a nice
guy all right make sure to create the
Trap let's do this let's see how
creative you can be let's see if they
can write the next saw installment let's
do this saw X ey saw levam all right
take it away John interior dimly lit
room night Paul pandemic Jones and uh
Brian Perry find themselves in a dimly
lit grim room their eyes adjust to the
darkness as they both realize they are
chained to opposite walls a large
electrical panel with tangled wires
between them above the panel a monitor
flickers on revealing the Eerie puppet
face of
Jigsaw hello Paul and Brian let's play a
game Paul your online Persona has
consumed you making you miss out on the
genuine experiences of life and Brian
despite your service you've made choices
that conflict with your role a protector
of
society uh to escape this room you must
literally reconnect with each other no
the screen shows a demonstration there
are 10 wires five from Paul's side and
five from Brian's they must match the
right wire to each side to form five
correct pairs a wrong match sends an
electrical shock this is like this video
game this is so light uh Paul your
thefts from The Real World represented
by the fruits of your la labor will
guide Brian and Brian your knowledge of
True Crime will help Paul but hurry you
have 5 minutes before the room becomes
your final resting place the screen goes
dark all right I'll be Brian all right
trying to maintain composure all right
pandemic let's put aside our differences
and work together I've faced tougher
situations in many years all right Old
Timer I must be all oh wa let's do it
again yeah all right then I don't know
how people sound
all right pmic let's put aside our
differences and we M together I faced
tougher situations in my years all right
Old Timer I might be all about the
digital world but right now we're very
much in the real one let's do this I to
see symbols in my end a melon an apple a
banana reminds me of Mel Gibson movie
when you was a thief I can't recall the
name of that movie movie what I think it
happened
once this is a real trap is to figure
out what that movie is uh those are the
fruits I stole match the melon with the
green wire on your side what symbols do
you have a a bloody C badge a wedding
ring a Medicare card a q symbol and an
online comment section okay connect to
the badge with the blue wire we've got
this minutes feel like hours as they
continue connecting wires get
uh minor shocks along the way but
ultimately finding the right connections
you know for someone who sayess with all
nine stuff you're not half bad in person
and for a cop with such a twisted past
you're not the worst partner in a tight
spot with the final wire connected the
chains release freeing them we did it
kid we sure did old man that's it they
that's all you could create escaped
deadly they also learn the they learn
the value of genuine connection what a
great setup you totally canned
everything about Paul I know you didn't
include Jolan I'm going to I'm going to
criticize you now Chad gbt notes rewrite
oh my God you didn't include Jack about
Paul's back background that we gave you
it was so light it was so
light apolog
all right we're going to redo this all
right we got the
Trap pass secret oh no there's a whole
different trap oh my God it's totally
redoing the SE oh it's redoing
everything P pandemic Jones and Brian
Perry are trapped in a room Bound by
chains between them are a series weights
and pulleys attached to Paul's side is a
heavy weight marked virtual world on
Brian's side there's an even heavier
weight label past Secrets above them a
tape recorder dangles as Paul manages to
nudge it and it begins to play
I yeah
sure should I say
pic JS are here
s you've been lost in the virtual world
so consumed by your digital life that
reality eludes you Brian your past is
heavy with Secrets weighing you down and
preventing you from moving forward today
you must face those burdens together
to escape ball you must physically lift
your weight symbolizing your online
obsessions Brian to help him reveal the
secret of every Milestone Paul achieves
making your weight lighter and easier to
lift if neither of you is honest or
committed neither of you gets out
remember sometimes the heaviest burdens
we carry are the ones we hide the tape
clicks off that's good all right there's
like two lines of dialogue let's see
what the hell they do okay struggling to
lift okay I'll admit it these glutes not
all natural I got implants but I tell
everyone I got there from
squats confession time okay wife number
two it wasn't a mysterious disappearance
she left me for a Mel Gibson
impersonator they continue in this vein
each Revelation lightening the weights
bit by bit I I might want to cause the
pandemic online and I'm terrified of
real life confrontations and I've never
actually confronted my feelings for well
real people I've scanned Medicare oh
true not because I needed the money but
because I felt invisible in my old age I
just wanted to feel
seen F finally finally after much effort
and the Revelation the chain release you
know for an old cop you've got quite the
story and you kid might want to spend a
bit more time in the real world it's not
all that
bad this was a better version Chad GPT I
like that Chad GPT came up with traps at
least these are jigsaw esque traps all
right in like 10 seconds it's not too
bad that's your shout out guys we tried
it we we did
[Music]
it